I didn't have a problem with this
country then all sudden they technically
made it illegal to be a Juggalo it's
like they took that one thing away then
made me not have a problem with the
government the way we take it it's like
you didn't come up the route everybody
comes up who's gonna step up worse you
know how would you fight this if this
was happening
[Music]
late one hot summer night crowds of
people gather in a remote wooded area
[Music]
everywhere faces are covered in clown
makeup and arms and legs are covered in
hatchet man tattoos
[Music]
by the end of the night everyone will be
covered in sticky cheap soda
[Music]
these people are called Juggalos and
they've come to see their favorite rap
group insane clown posse Juggalos had
built a cultural identity around the
music the rap duo and what it represents
in turn ICP has stood up for its
followers after they've been harassed
and profiled all over the country as the
FBI has tried to force Juggalos to
retreat back into the shadows these two
white rappers from Detroit have
unwittingly become some of the nation's
most determined advocates for free
expression many of you may never have
even heard of the group I see the Insane
Clown Posse is a rap group known for its
violent a dynamic duo driving their fans
into a frenzy
Liuzza's rappers you don't say that's it
we just want to rap be on a major label
and rap for a living that's what we want
to do that's Shaggy 2 dope and here's
fine l'chaim
because we came up with nothing [ __ ]
dirt-poor bottom of the barrel is [ __ ]
grimy as you can possibly beat ICP
started off like most struggling artists
using a basement to make their first
recording you believe in a secret right
you know what the secret is and laws of
attraction on it we were fully putting
that energy out as kids fully and in it
was just destiny posses interesting
they've been around for ever you know
they've been around for over 25 years we
caught up with Nathan Rabin at his motel
in Oklahoma City where he was in the
middle of writing about the 2017
gathering of the Juggalos he's a pop
culture writer and has written
extensively on Juggalos and insane clown
posse
you know they're really kind of these
white high school dropouts from Detroit
who discovered a horrorcore music which
is a glory violent kind of over-the-top
sort of like horror movie isn't but in
sort of audio form
but these rappers from Southwest
Detroit's say they are sending out a
positive message calling on listeners to
wipe out racism bigotry drugs and
careless sex the music spoke to poor
scrubby white kids who identified with
Shaggy 2 dope and violent J kids who
grew up in broken homes or sleeping in
cars kids that don't have traditional
families we represent people that have
been that they were born without the
silver spoon in the mouth but instead
with a rusty fork but you see a fair
amount of diversity you'll see black
gigolos drug loading and wheelchairs
again I think peels to outsiders the
underdog persona started to inform what
ICP did on stage and then they kind of
stumbled upon this gimmick where they
would dress up like clowns all these
people that they view the underclass
poor people as like carnival freaks and
that's why we wear two clown makeup and
that's also why ICP brought the cheap
soda brand Faygo on stage to let the
audience know that they should embrace
where they came from one of the group's
favorite gimmicks fountains if a go pop
spring endlessly into the adoring
audience so that became part of their
whole spectacle as a dress up like
clowns and they perform the core core
music and it's crazy
audiences with Faygo now they have a
cult-like following and sellout every
concert they play in Metro Detroit and
they developed a reputation bifurcated
you know they had fans they were had
kind of this period in the 90s when they
almost broke into the mainstream where
they had flattened records where MTV was
kind of interested in them they were on
you know major labels and that never
really happened
it seems like ICP didn't fit in anywhere
in mainstream music in 1997 they had
their album pulled from stores by their
mainstream record label ICP with Disney
record label for being inappropriate and
to equip it then came another setback
they performed in Woodstock 99 which to
me is really interesting is that was
just a total [ __ ] show and also kind of
a big turning point for the gathering
where they're kind of like we don't
belong and the Woodstock 99 Belle
Woodstock 1999 was the corporate version
of Woodstock 1969 complete with
expensive ticket prices multiple
sponsors and overpriced water also it
ended in fires and looting so ICP turned
inward releasing music on their own and
creating a world for themselves and
Juggalos to exist so the next year they
began the gathering of the Juggalos the
festival has been held in different
cities since 2000 and it attracts
thousands of Juggalos from across the
nation and they would get kicked out in
various states they've been Convention
Center as a hater though the convention
centers they would just kind of get
kicked out of everywhere in 2017 it was
held just outside of Oklahoma City at
this wooded campground and they
developed kind of this notoriety and the
notoriety was partially based on you
know the music of violin Jay and Shaggy
2 dope and part of the notoriety was
based on the fans
you know they're very easy to make fun
of their the poor white people that
everybody has no problem mocking if you
don't move we'll be back you're no
longer fresh your stale the difference
between fresh and stale is common sense
you either ripe or you're not whoo whoo
stale Juggalos became pop culture
punchline a long long time ago and it
has remained a very popular pop culture
punchline but I CPUs the punchline
status to bolster their fans they gave
us something to believe in
yes we feel like whatever the magic is
this bringing us all together whatever
the magic is their hearing is the same
magic we're feeling so when they say hey
you guys saved my life are you guys this
and that you know got me through [ __ ]
school you listening it's them that did
that [ __ ] you don't say like um work
this [ __ ] saved our life too
like by ninja forgot is out for his
whole wardrobe and ninjas are just
throwing them stuff to make sure that
he's not over here struggling you know
he can get clean that's my friend my
family
ninjas is another word for it it's very
validating and exciting to you around
people who love you you know just
because of what you do and what you like
and there's like this freedom you know
that that you find out the gathering you
don't really place find anywhere else
it seemed like ICP had finally found the
success that they wanted the rap duo had
their own place in music and Juggalos
had formed a community they never had
before
but then something totally surprising
happened they may look like clowns but
feds are taking them seriously
the FBI has identified fans of the rap
group insane clown posse as America's
newest gang when we first heard about it
we were just like that's pretty cool
though it's funny like I know all the
the nation's top gangs actually think
we're a gang we must really be out there
what's it like it was cool we had no
idea of any repercussions that we're
gonna be they were gonna happen because
the FBI has legal approval to basically
profile Juggalos and if they see
somebody with a hatchet man decal and
they're on the back of their truck you
know they can pull them over yeah yeah I
know I've been [ __ ] pulled over you
know cuz I [ __ ] had some a sticker on
my car they're like why are you in a
gang or something and the cop was like
oh so you're just into this gang stuff
you're not a member of it we're like
what gang stuff it's music then ICP
started hearing stories about people
losing their jobs or being denied
custody of their children over being a
Juggalo it seemed like the sort of
enthusiasm they made sense at the
gathering or at an ICP concert was
getting Juggalos into trouble in the
mainstream world like your home so like
a massive level I didn't have a problem
with this country then all sudden they
technically made it illegal to be a
Juggalo
it's like they took that one thing away
that made me not have a problem with the
government the way we take it it's like
you didn't come up the route everybody
comes up you can come up the same
avenues everybody uses to come up you
didn't sell your idea to a corporation
and use them to put it all over the
world you know I'm saying so it's like
[ __ ] you know you know yeah now the mana
buy so they're like you know we're not
gonna let that happen we're gonna find a
way to [ __ ] you up you know and they did
not mean they totally did and it's not
just about [ __ ] us up it's [ __ ] up
anybody who's down with us who listens
to us who represents what we represent
you know saying is so it's not just us
you know saying is it affects people
that listen to us more than it affects
us and when I say ah
I mean right us you know as rose
[Music]
Insane Clown Posse versus the US
Department of Justice well tonight the
Michigan bass rat metal duo is suing the
government over a gang designation
general is it being [ __ ] with we got to
do something about it you don't say if
that ties us into some kind of first
amendment move it
whatever we're First Amendment warriors
I don't know in this country we have the
right to listen to the music we want and
associate with fellow fans without being
subjected to harassment or criminal
profiling what do they do when the judge
meets with the the attorneys or whatever
and decides if the case is worthy we
didn't even make it past that stage
[ __ ] got thrown out of court three
times right no saying never even made it
to court actually so you know just
people getting thrown in jail and you
know all this [ __ ] for no reason you
don't say it wasn't important enough to
take to a trial no nothing to it you
don't say any [ __ ] let her go to jail
who cares you know my question is
where's the [ __ ] Calvary where's
[ __ ] any better where's Neil Young
worse [ __ ] all these guys those
activists where are these because it's
not just an insane clown posse I think
it's our First Amendment thing it's a
freedom of speech thing it's you know
freedom to assemble it's freedom of
self-expression there's always gonna be
a couple bad apples and it's not fair to
basically villainize every single other
person just because of a couple bad if
you told me all had getting this music
you're part of the gang I would've been
like well that's not what I'm [ __ ]
down with but when I listen to music and
it tells me to be a better person to
live a better life treat people fairly
and [ __ ] live the best the [ __ ]
that I can on this earth that's what I'm
down with that so done for and that to
me that's there's no gang that preaches
bad what should we do you know how would
you fight this if this was happening to
you whatever musician or [ __ ]
anything out there how would you fight
this
[Music]
it seems ICP and Juggalos are being
forced to take a step into the
mainstream world again they'll be
marching on Washington in September 2017
to protest the FBI's gang designation
well who's gonna step up for us you know
say so far nobody so if we don't do it
this is gonna be left the gang you know
I'm saying it's probably is anyhow but
at least we got something to say about
it we're definitely going to watching
into March
cuz [ __ ] all the [ __ ] that comes
along with the police I'm going my kids
are going I'm we have five rooms or in
it my homeboy is written a 10-person ban
it's a publicity stunt 100% because we
want to say to everybody we're not cool
with that
we're just trying to Adam all [ __ ]
look at y'all's in a different light
that's all we're doing you don't saying
so he can get a fair shake of life it's
infuriating [ __ ] [ __ ] man that's
why we're marching this is our lifestyle
this is our life gigolos our America
that's the America that I really do you
know that's the America that speaks to
me it's you know America Outsiders
weird-ass people aren't accepted you
know don't belong other places only in
America
that's right
[Music]
you